thank you so much for having me here
today I really appreciate them focus for
putting this fantastic conference
together and it's really an honor to be
here so let's talk a little bit about
Memex just to get started as she said
I'm Katrina Riehl I'm the co-principal
investigator for the continuum team
working on the Memex project under DARPA
we're actually on two different teams on
this project so we actually work with
with NASA JPL kitware so we have one
team er there and then we also work with
NYU on another team so we actually have
two different teams that we work with on
this on this project and I'm gonna talk
about the work that we do with both of
them so the first thing I wanted to
start with is when you ask the internet
a question who do you think is answering
you right in most cases all of us are
going to a commercial search engine we
go through and we take our keywords and
we've typed them into the computer and
we have some business in the background
that has gone out and done all this
search for us created indexes and giving
us back results that are highly filtered
right they are giving us what they their
view of the Internet is so why do people
don't seem to realize that there is just
a surface of the web that we're actually
getting views into when we do a search
with a commercial search engine all
we're seeing is that surface web
underneath what is visible through
commercial and normal search methods is
this whole other layer of the Internet
that right now is very difficult to see
you have to know exactly where you're
going to you have to understand more
about the internet and more about how to
get to these places in order to grab
that kind of content so what am I
talking about here so we're really
talking about only 15% of the Internet
is actually visible people may not
realize that beneath that in the Deep
Web there's actually the largest growing
portion of content on the internet right
now and this includes dynamic content
multimedia content things that are not
traditionally text content
and we're trying to get to that sort of
material out on the internet and make it
credit available and accessible and I
also want to make the distinction
between the Deep Web and the dark web so
some people probably heard of the dark
web this is where a lot of people you
have to use tor sites onion sites things
like that you have to use a tor browser
in order to go into that part of the the
Internet where it's very much anonymized
in order to in order to get to that kind
of material I'm gonna focus mostly on
the Deep Web so this is using just
regular most you know your normal
internet protocols where we're talking
about information that's publicly
available on the Deep Web it's just
below the surface what makes it special
is the visibility it's not readily
available to us so I want to talk a
little bit about the DARPA memetics
program I started in September 2014 and
we're talking and we have about 17 teams
from all over the country that are all
working on this problem what we're doing
is we're trying to find a different way
to look at the web and be able to
conduct searches on the web and in some
ways are actually trying to democratize
search when DARPA was looking at the at
the Internet they saw this
one-size-fits-all approach where people
were searching the Internet in much the
same way and not really having any sort
of novel approaches right we're looking
at companies that are really based on
advertising they're trying to sell us
things they're filtering the results
that they're giving back to us based on
the ability to sell us things and so
they wanted to create all of these tools
that are available on an open source
platform for us to be able to search the
internet better and so why does this
matter for you know why is the
government interested in this right well
because there are a lot of search
parameters that are not they're not
normal right we're looking at things
that nefarious activities that may be
taking place on the internet things like
human trafficking looking at illicit
pharmaceuticals being sold but more
importantly I think by making these
tools open-source to everyone what
they're allowing people to do is
conduct their own sort of searches as I
mentioned before there's a huge rich
amount of information available in the
Deep Web
so for businesses you can imagine that
this might be a really good place to
mine information about other businesses
you're considering doing business with
form data being able to actually look at
you know presentations by people who
have actually worked at that company and
find more information about them or in
an investment opportunity maybe you want
to do a very thorough search in that
entire area and get a better lay of the
land and where investment opportunities
may lie so in the Memex program we're
really taking you know several different
disciplines and putting them all
together we're looking at high
performance computing information
retrieval machine learning and and then
just traditional you know web scraping
technologies and indexing all all in the
same area so this collaboration is
happening across all the different teams
and so I just wanted to really talk
about like the reason that they've
gotten into this area is primarily
because of Silk Road this is actually
something that took place on the dark
web so this isn't in the Deep Web and in
the dark web the there was a sighting
run Silk Road where illegal drugs were
being sold their allegations and
murder-for-hire all sorts of things that
were happening on this in this area that
were not readily visible to others so
this program kind of came out of that
out of that um use case we actually are
working on several different domains all
the teams are working on all of these
domains so we're applying these these
technologies into human labor
trafficking child exploitation weapons
so tracking illegally sold or firearms
all across the internet illicit
pharmaceuticals I'm sure all of you
who've received you know spam emails you
know guaranteeing you drugs from
whatever materials research science and
autonomous systems research both of
these are kind of interesting because
they're both domains where we're
actually trying to index PDF documents
or scientific data
is out there so published results from
or proceedings from conferences that are
not readily available and gives search
tools on top of those to give you know
more information about the content
inside of those different domains and
then also financial fraud and
counterfeiting onyx counterfeit
electronics I think is really
interesting because in this case we're
actually doing a lot of image processing
we also are in human labor trafficking
as well we're actually able to take
images pull out information and index
based on location pull out information
about the background who's involved in
the picture track where they're going
how see movements as they move across
the internet whether or not the inner
the picture is showing up in different
places with different organizations
things like that and counterfeit
electronics we're really also trying to
find mostly electronics that are
entering the supply chain for military
forces that are that may have sabotage
your backdoor capabilities built into
them so we're looking for things that
have had some sort of tampering involved
there and comparing images to see
whether or not they're actually
receiving the electronics that were
actually ordered as I mentioned before I
just want to stress all of this is open
source you can go to open catalog DARPA
mill and click on the Memex program and
all of the teams have their open source
software available there also you know I
just want to mention our team here at
continuum everything's built on the
Anaconda Clapp platform so we actually
have Conda packages for most of the
things that we work on so you can
actually can't install several the
things I'm going to talk about here so
before we actually kind of dive into the
tools that we've been building I just
want to talk a little bit about the
ecosystem for building a system like
this like what sort of pieces are we
looking at when we want to architect a
system that does this right as I
mentioned before we're taking all of
these different areas and kind of
pushing them together and we want to
pick the best technologies and make them
work well together I know that I've run
into this situation where I've looked at
a lot of open source projects and I
thought wow that is really cool
capability
now how do I actually use it in a larger
context how do I make it talk to this
other system how do I put these two
together right so here I just wanted to
talk a little bit about that and so
we're looking at you know the basic
business intelligence database
technologies probably everyone is
familiar you know MongoDB MySQL all of
these different backends for storing
data in the data mining machine learning
stats area we have you know nom and our
scikit-learn wake up
pandas all of these different areas
scientific computing I think most people
are here definitely familiar with
working with Sai pine numpy number goes
into this area as well as pi tables
things like that and in the distributed
system we have Hadoop and Palo hive
SPARC and then we have a bunch of
different things that crossover between
different areas so for example I just
wanted to mention you know mahute and
our hadoop as well because these have
machine learning capabilities built into
them and also spark ml was another one
that I wanted to mention is also
available so we have all of these
difficulty of this huge landscape of
tools but we want to be able to look at
and put together into a system and make
it actually function and they in a in an
easy way we want people to be able to do
this easily and put the the power of
search back into people's hands how are
we going to take all of these different
things put it into a platform that makes
sense
without making ourselves inside and also
distribute it so I just want to talk a
little bit about the analytics pipeline
and we'll talk more about the tools in a
minute so this is actually a very normal
pipeline that we're talking about we
send out crawlers just like every other
commercial search engine does out there
we go out and like crawl different areas
to seed it and and crawl and scrape
different things we're gonna extract
entities from that content that we've
pulled we're gonna index that and then
on top of that we want to build
applications and tools and different
analytics on top of that in order to
tell what kind of contact we content
we've actually run into the thing I want
to also mention here as I said before
though what makes this special is that
we're going into areas of the Internet
where we might be looking at dynamic
content we might be looking at
multimedia content or it might be
actually indexing images or audio files
or something like that so it's not we're
we're augmenting it slightly
we're also talking about a much larger
area right where we're trying to get to
an area that is much much larger than
the 15% of the internet that we actually
see and then we also want to create
search tools that look at the data in a
novel way I don't know about you guys
but I mean I never click on to the
second page after I do a search right
but it would be nice to have some sort
of characterization of what other
information may be in that area for me
to expand my search or for me to be able
to find things that I didn't know even
existed or even suggest trending areas
in that domain that I might want to look
at so it's remem Explorer so this idea
here is to create a pluggable framework
where people are able to run their own
searches you can seed mimics explore any
way you want it's a django application
you can we're currently even working on
putting a cluster behind it so that you
might be able to even scale it out and
index much larger amounts of data we
basically take everything that we run
into and we're gonna throw it into an
elastic search index and then on top of
that we're going to create
visualizations or different dashboards
in order to look at the content that
we're we're talking about here and this
kind of gets back to the to the work
that we've been doing with our different
partners so NASA JPL are very involved
in the Apache community so we have the
Apache nut crawler on one side and then
we also have the NYU ashay crawler
available as well so we have these two
different crawlers that are both
accessible through MMX Explorer and the
nice thing about both of these is that
you can do directed crawling so we can
actually train different models and
upload them into the crawler and
determine relevance so I'll talk a
little bit more about that in a minute
but mostly we've been using naive Bayes
models in order to determine relevance
and that will help us determine
it's the crawl into areas that are
interesting to us but and more
importantly their it also kind of helps
hold down the data and make it makes it
a much more focused data set and then
another thing I wanted to mention as
well as NYU's domain discovery tool
which is a very it actually uses a
commercial search engine in order to
seed a search goes out and finds
information about that area and then you
can label different pages as relevant or
irrelevant and spit out a model so from
there it's actually going to use wake a
to train a machine learning model use
that you can upload it into a chain at
that point you can do your directed
crawling and I also wanted to mention we
have done a couple of collaborations as
I mentioned before this is on the
anaconda platform we've really tried to
keep this very modular so the idea being
that you have this whole suite of tools
that you'd be able to pick and choose
are most appropriate to your domain and
then be able to customize it for the
particular search that you're trying to
create
so with Carnegie Mellon University they
created a time anomaly detection tool
which mostly you know obviously for
financial data or things that have time
series data available in them in order
to find anomalies in there and then it
also uses a bouquet dashboards and
things like that in order to visualize
results and then also we have a cetera
data weight plugin this is a new
collaboration that we've been working on
where they actually have a Firefox
plugin that will follow the movements of
a subject matter expert as they do an
investigation on the Internet and kind
of follows them it collects metadata
about what they're looking at URLs that
they're visiting information about what
they're actually seeing but then we can
take the results from that trail of
investigation import it into mimics
Explorer we can possibly even edit the
seed list and then use it to in order to
expand the search out into an into areas
that they may not have actually seen
before or that might be interesting to
them
so mentioned before with a jet
propulsion laboratory and they're
working on nut which is uh as you see a
highly extensible highly scalable web
crawler the nice thing about nuts is
that it does have a politeness factor
and inherent to it so it's not going to
overload servers it's a little bit
you're not as likely to get blocked put
it that way as you're trying to crawl
different sites and then also Apache
tikka and I can't say enough about
Apache tikka I think that this is a
fantastic tool this is our first round
of extraction where we're using tika to
pull content out of what we're looking
at and this this also does rich content
types so you can use PDF you can look at
powerpoints you can use all sorts of
different things things that are not
normally even even indexed in the
regular internet and so and the other
nice thing I also just women working on
automatic translation services and
different multimedia types are also
being worked into TK right now I also
want to mention especially since we are
at PI data that we do have Python front
ends to both of these so there's a nudge
Python that's available and Atika python
available both of them have restful
services available for you to basically
query and use the services to to look at
content and also talking about NYU's
work on a che and the domain discovery
tool as I mentioned before both of these
are freely available out on github and
they're available through the open
catalog on through DARPA so this is a as
I mentioned before this is a joint
there's a cooperative effort on all of
our sides all everyone's you know
participating this one so NYU and and
JPL both have have contributed to MMX
explore and the idea here as I mentioned
before is for it to to create an
application specifically tailored to
your domain and here in the screenshot
you can actually see we're using bouquet
to give you crawl statistics as you're
actually moving through data
here this is actually an Aussie crawl so
we have a naive based classifier working
as where as we're crawling and you can
kind of see where the domains are being
crawled over here and then the harvest
plot what are we finding that is
relevant so we're not crawling beyond
things that we find that are irrelevant
we're not going to waste our time moving
down into the depths of an area that
doesn't look interesting to us we're
able to to get that feedback as we're
moving through the crawl and and and
move into areas that are interesting as
I mentioned before this bit is on top of
the Anaconda platform we do have a Memex
channel as I mentioned before so we have
kind of packages for almost everything
and another thing that's kind of
interesting about this I just want to
mention that we have you know since you
you can package pretty much anything
that says it's an executable so we've
had Conda packages where we actually
deploy docker containers we've had Conda
packages where we deploy Java programs
we've we've packaged a lot of things so
we've used our we've used Java we've
used C C++ we've used pretty much
everything you can imagine we've
packaged in some sort of Conda package
and made available which is I mean just
an incredibly powerful platform to use
also I wanted to do Travis said quite a
bit about blaze so I'm gonna skip some
of this but we do use blaze to sort of
provide that the uniform API that we're
looking for so you can imagine we have a
lot of data coming in and we want to be
able to compare so for example if you
look at something like I've been doing
investigations in financial fraud so I'm
gonna use that as an example good so we
might have company information coming in
as well as blue sheet information coming
in we may have ticker data coming in and
then also we have sentiment analysis
that we want to do out on the on the
internet or in different forums that
we've actually directed our crawler to
and then we want to be able to actually
take all of these different data sources
and pull them all together in some way
that makes sense and we use dentin plays
in order to do that
as a minute I'll skip this part I also
wanted to talk a little bit about
bouquet so this is provides the
interactive visualizations that your
that you saw before so I was just
showing you a screenshot using the OSH a
crawler where we're actually getting
feedback from the crawler as its as its
crawling and then we provide it we
actually get bouquet visualizations
built on the fly from those results and
and display them as its as its crawling
I also wanted to mention scikit-learn we
use this extensively in order to do a
lot of modeling we were mostly working
with unstructured data so we try we use
quite a bit of clustering in order to
look at what is out there and
characterize what we're seeing we also
use quite a bit of classification if
we're able to actually propagate labels
but like denoting relevance for example
then we'll we'll frame it more as a
classification problem before I move on
I just want to do a quick demo so here's
my mix Explorer up and working the idea
here is that if we wanted to create a
new project these would coincide with
the different domains that I mentioned
before so maybe you wanted to start an
investigation and human trafficking or
you wanted to create a domain for
material research science or something
like that in this case I created a
project called test which is actually
focused on financial fraud so what I've
done here is you can when I move here to
seeds you can see the different trails
where I've actually had my subject
matter expert use the plug-in in Firefox
create different trails that give me
information about where an investigator
might look for information when they're
investigating in this area so this is
not displaying correctly on for Safari
so I'm going to skip it but the idea
here is that we can take this trail edit
it create a seed list and then what we
move over to mimics Explorer I come in
to test
if I want to start a new crawl I can
actually pick up that seed list so that
seed list that I would have created from
the from the data wag trail I can create
it here give all the parameters for my
different crawl I can put some metadata
associated with it specify which which
crawler I want to use and then how many
rounds deep I want to go so how far do I
want this to fan out you can set it
really really high right or as you're
tuning it you might want to set it a
little bit lower just to make sure that
your classifier is working correctly and
that you're getting information that
makes sense to you once you set the
crawl working I'm actually going to show
you the other screenshot I showed you
was from a notch a crawl this is
actually from a nudge crawl here the
nice thing here is we actually have this
crawl monitor so you can start and stop
your crawls up here you can see how many
rounds left you have and then you can
see as it's moving through all of these
different sites how long it's taking and
this kind of gives you an idea you can
see how the crawler is actually
performing which is interesting I find
it interesting especially because we do
find some sites where you might get
stuck where things might not quite work
the way you think that they might or you
might end up running into some content
that we don't normally handle just yet
especially as we're handling dynamic
content that is probably the most
challenging part of of crawling in this
domain once we've actually done the
crawl I just wanted to show you we have
these Kabana dashboards as I mentioned
before we're using elasticsearch on the
back end so all of the information is
running through teeka we're doing our
initial extraction using tika it's
moving into elastic search from elastic
search I'm able to actually create these
dashboards on the fly using cabaña which
is also freely available this is not a
very compelling visualization right here
but very quickly you can see that you
know I took content from the internet I
I crawled 421 pages and I was able to
see content and then get an idea of what
my term frequency is just that easily
and they have these nice dialogue
for creating the visualization so it's
very very very easy to put these
together ultimately we want to as we're
we're building up our visualization
toolkit we're gonna move to bouquet
dashboards for everything so right now
we're only visualizing sort of crawl
statistics as we're moving through the
crawl with with bouquet but ultimately
we want to be able to move all of these
dashboards into an interactive setting
because right there here there is some
interaction so you can see data as
you're moving through it but you don't
you can't necessarily interact with the
data select portions of the data drill
down into the data things like that and
I also mentioned the New York
University's a domain discovery tool I
just wanted to really quickly show you
this one I actually pre-populated this
one with I created a crawler called SEC
and then for the web search I used words
like penny stock guaranteed results big
money you know things like that things
that you might find with somebody who's
trying to lure somebody into a pump and
dump scheme right so these all represent
sites and then we have terms over on the
side that kind of tell you where they
came from
as you move over them you can kind of
get an idea of what the context is that
that term is coming from the cool thing
here is that then you know you may want
to look at different ways that these are
clustering right here we're just using a
CPC a so principal component analysis in
order to look and see what we're what
kind of clusters we're looking at here
but then I can actually I'll select some
and then as I come down here I can see a
preview of what has actually been picked
up from that website and then I can
start tagging relevance or irrelevance
right
and put in let's say this one's neutral
things like that so as I move down here
or up here if you want to tag them all
at the same time and so my blue dots are
now tagged as relevant my red dots are
now irrelevant and then over here on
this side
in theory you should be able to see how
many relevant irrelevant terms are
showing up on this side but so once we
have all of our tags created though so
we've seeded this search we've gone out
we pulled content we now have all these
significant terms we're just using these
the words we're not doing any kind of
stemming or any kind of by grams or
trigrams or anything like that just
using words as features we can go ahead
and actually train a model so just by
clicking on this model button up at the
top we're gonna call to wake a we're
gonna use our features and we're going
to train a naive Bayes model which then
gets spit out which we can use in our
crawl upload into Memex Explorer and
then uses a crawl and just also wanted
to mention real quick some of the other
capabilities we have in here
if you do already have a collection of
documents that you've pulled together or
you've been collecting PDFs on something
forever something like that you can
actually just use the add new data set
and upload it to the site yourself it'll
automatically run everything through
teeka and index it just like the rest of
the of the workflow work so you have
access to all of the visualizations
without actually having to run the
crawler so moving back over here so now
we've collected all this data you can
see that we've pulled in some crawl
statistics we have all this content we
have a bunch of unstructured data that
we can look at in very rough sort of
ways and tagged as being relevant or
irrelevant we can train models and
things like that but when we pull a
large amount of data back what how are
we going to characterize what's in it so
let's say that we've got terabytes of
data coming back to us it's not just
something where we're looking at four
hundred and twenty-one documents right
and this small crawl that I did here
this actually we're using topic modeling
as a first pass the idea here this is
actually a it's we have a topic library
that's actually started by Christine dua
over here and the idea here is that it's
a basically an unsupervised clustering
algorithm where you're able to find
topics so if you think of each word as
being having the probability of
contributing to a topic that's what
we're really looking at so it's not
really a document that's going to
contribute to the document to to the
topic we're going to talk about the
words themselves so the words will
organize into these different clusters
where we can actually look and see what
sort of topics are coming out in this
unstructured way one way to visualize
this you can see that obviously this is
a bouquet plot as well when looking at
termite plots here one problem with with
the topic modeling is that we actually
do have to specify the number of
clusters that we're going to create so
if you think of the x-axis as the number
of clusters each cluster number you're
seeing a
what words contributed to that
particular cluster so we don't have yet
a way to name the topics but we can get
an idea of what's in them so for example
in this one I think this one is actually
showing oh this the material sciences so
you can see different trending topics
and material sciences so what's what's
hot it there it was interesting when we
did this on autonomy domain actually we
were able to see things like droned
literature kind of picked up we were
able to see trends where neural networks
became less popular and we were able to
see more drone technologies showing up
in the literature and and especially it
and you could see all these things just
kind of clustering and clopin and moving
together which was very interesting and
then also we have the LD Ava's available
here the nice thing here I wish I had a
I don't unfortunately I don't have a
live demo of this but you can see all
the different clusters created here on
the left hand side as you mouse over
them they light up red and then you can
see sort of the overlap of how the words
in that particular topic compared to
others so it's just comparing it to the
rest of the content that you've pulled
and then as I mentioned before we're
using elasticsearch and Cabana you saw
the Cabana dashboard it wasn't like I
said it was not a very compelling
demonstration of her of Cabana
dashboards but this one is a little bit
more interesting you see that it's
automatically discretized our time
series so this is looking at trending
terms on corals that have been done over
time so we can pull in data and see how
things have changed so even if you
especially as you're looking at dynamic
content you may find that you have very
very different information coming to you
some parts of the Internet are changing
very very rapidly or as you can imagine
some of the more how should I put it I
some of the domains that we look at are
very ephemeral people are trying to hide
their identities
they're trying to make it very difficult
to track movements so we can see how
things have changed over time and we can
identify areas where we may want to
crawl more often in order to be able to
grab content so I think that's pretty
pretty cool visualization I kind of flew
through this pretty quickly so uh does
anyone have any questions
happy to answer any questions yes Oh
yes the question was whether or not
we're using any graph databases or graph
technologies not currently that's
actually something that we're very
interested in using I know that dado
opens sourced some of their graph
technologies recently and we've been
looking at trying to incorporate that
into this because I think it's very
applicable to this domain yes I'm sorry
right now we're just using elasticsearch
we do use some other databases just for
keeping metadata as we're crawling and
things like that but primarily
elasticsearch on the image processing we
were using solar so but also leucine
based so we would kind of move between
those two solar and elasticsearch yes
back here you yes
yeah you
uh-huh
right that's actually an open research
topic for us creating a name for a topic
is extraordinarily hard there a couple
different things we've actually been
trying to do with the with the topic
modeling and I just and I also wanted to
mention that we've been so we do have
two different algorithms implemented
we're using the PLS a so the
probabilistic latent semantic analysis
and then we're also using LD a the
latent early analysis and so and then we
have two different backends for this so
we are using the ability to run on just
a single machine and then we also have
the ability to actually using anaconda
cluster move to a much larger back-end
so what's nice here is we're able to
kind of configure it depending on how we
assume how big the domain is going to be
right but every experiment that I've
done trying to seed clusters everything
that I've done trying to direct clusters
or try to manipulate it in any sort of
way usually ends up in a big mess I
actually end up with huge kind of
dribbly clusters that end up all over
the place and don't really give you any
information at all or I end up with
something that you know it it just
really doesn't characterize well but as
far as actually coming up with a a
keyword term or something that will
actually describe that right now we're
just using frequency in order to
determine what's actually out there and
you know that seems to be working well
enough for now yeah
over here
right since we're not looking at text
right we're so we do have some selenium
solutions where we're actually clicking
around and trying to get JavaScript to
return and then we can actually look at
the JavaScript right but that in that
case we end up basically with a headless
browser which is kind of a strange
situation to be in right we would like
to be able to create a situation where
we can interact with a database or
interact with it with a website and get
smart content back without actually
having to move to that level so we're we
are looking for solutions that go beyond
the sort of headless browser situation
so it but yeah as you click around as
you put information into forms as you
you know put input into the system being
able to get content back that you can
then characterize is very very difficult
no we're actually trying to create smart
ways to talk to the different sites so I
don't know if maybe I'll have seen the
Google tools that will answer your email
for you all right so it trains itself on
your own emails and then it'll create an
email from you actually for people right
the idea there right is that we want to
be able to train something to interact
with the website in an intelligent
fashion and be able to actually pull
content out in a way that makes sense we
don't just want to try every single
permutation and see where it crashes
right we'd rather actually have
something that worked well but also open
research every year - yes
yes I actually not doing a local in demo
today I actually was using our server
but I I do have this up and running on
my local machine no problem
yes
yeah actually that is an interesting
thing to talk about so privacy issues
are something that we all take pretty
seriously right we are looking for this
is all publicly available information
we're not trying to break into sites and
pull anything out but it would be
considered illegal or anything like that
we're only looking for content that is
freely available out on the Internet
right but we yeah just as a rule we're
basically trying to preserve that sort
of privacy but there is nothing
formalized in that in that way right so
but we're not trying to get into you
know medical records or any sort of you
know insurance information or things
like that right it's just we're pointing
it at areas where people are you know
sex trafficking human trafficking those
areas right there
yes
that's actually some of me just put in a
proposal for so being able to actually
estimate the size of the domain it's
very difficult right I mean because
these are not traditionally indexed
areas of the web and if you think about
it you know the web can be especially if
you're looking at dynamic content
I am the infinite right I go all over
the place and so but we have been kind
of discussing different metrics to
determine completeness especially as
we're doing directed crawling I think
that we'll be able to use something
along the lines of like a semi
supervised situation where we actually
are able to cluster propagate labels and
then crawl and then feed it back in
order to determine a steady state at
that point I think we can safely say
that we have exhausted that particular
area but we're not totally sure yet open
research
yes
we're so the different teams are
publishing on the tools that they're
developing so and the technologies and
techniques that they're they're actually
creating the data that's actually pulled
from this this project that's being
delivered to the different law
enforcement agencies is theirs they're
actually opening active investigations
and using it in order to to prosecute
so no data is coming out of it
all right well thank you so much I
appreciate it